between the election and the pandemic
people have been glued to their screens
lately
social media usage is higher than it's
ever been before
but a growing number of people are
getting off social media altogether
this new ad targets people who are
considering deleting their accounts
take a look more and more people
are finding themselves dangerously
addicted to social media
the average user now reports spending
three hours per day
online they're spending money on phone
jails and therapy to quit their
addiction to facebook
instagram twitter and tick tock
but not linkedin that's because linkedin
is the only social network that is
proven to be 100
non-addictive in fact our users spend
less than five minutes per day on
linkedin
and many spend zero minutes per day you
won't have to struggle to stop using it
because you already aren't so join the
millions of people who have probably
forgotten they have linkedin accounts
and get back to enjoying your life have
you ever heard anyone say they're eating
too many raisins
exactly linkedin were the raisins of
social media